the jogan experience and I think trauma
I think childhood trauma I think uh
childhood trauma kind of can uh can make
you depressed yeah for sure yeah for
sure I think that especially abuse yeah
abuse seems like the one that people
have the hardest time shaking was
because it's not that they weren't even
it wasn't even that they were ignored is
that someone prayed on them yeah and
they gave they have no selfworth they're
beaten you they have no selfworth and
they know that uh the younger the abuse
or the neglect happened the more of an
imprint it it leaves because your brain
is forming and it's fascinating stuff
man but we have neuroplasticity and you
can go to therapy and edmr is something
I'm doing and it's incredible it's the
only thing I've ever done that sort of
works what is that edmr was invented by
Francine Shapiro like in the 80s
accidentally she's a psychologist and
now it's become sort of the uh gold
standard for trauma treatment and PTSD
and like vet hospitals and stuff and
what it is is it's um uh I uh Ed it's uh
eye movement desensi uh
desensitization and reprocessing and so
so it involves moving your eyes in a
very specific way while you process
traumatic memories yeah I'm doing it
now it's crazy oh my God you're hacking
your brain you hack your brain and you
get into your subconscious like your REM
uh State and then you reprocess the
memories and when you're there you start
having Vivid memories and then when
you're done memories start flying in out
of nowhere whoa how did you find out
about this this is wild it was sort of
it was interesting I was in LA right so
I um you know I have Early Childhood
trauma and then I've had some traumatic
things happen to me later in life and
then the panic attack started after I
got shot when I was in my early 20s I
didn't know what they were back then
like I just didn't know what they were
so I'd just be having these panic
attacks in the train just going like
what is happening to me so I've been
dealing with it for like 20 years and it
would go away for periods i' have great
periods and then it would come back and
and um after I had kids I think I called
you I did I spoke to you once and you
were very helpful but after I had kids
it sort of
triggered um a lot of these feelings
that would come up out of nowhere and
sadness I'd be looking at my kids and
I'd get sad I'd be playing with them I'd
get sad and I didn't understand it and
then I'd be in a hotel room and on the
road and I'd just start like panicking
and be like what is this and so I was
talking to my friend uh Tracy carazo um
she's she's a comic in New York she's
funny and she's one of these Italian
girls who's just got a guy for
everything she's just you ask her atie
she's like I I know somebody so she
asked she was like how are you and I
just answered honestly I was like ah I
did and I gave her like a
paragraph and she sound she was like it
sounds like you didn't feel safe as a
kid she was like uh let me get you in
touch with this person who I'm friends
with who does edmr and then I got in
touch with this therapist and she's
incredible and um I started the edmr
journey and it's been it's the only
thing I've done and edmr has a beginning
middle and end it's not like you know it
it's not like ad infite just goes on
forever it's like you're there to
reprocess this trauma and so do you do
it at a specific place I do it I do it
Zoom I love to zoom you zoom yeah so you
zoom with someone who guides you through
it is that how it works yeah and you do
it how often I'm doing it now twice a
week but you can do it once a week and
how long is each session hour she'll go
longer sometimes though wow so what what
do you do you feel like the chemicals
moving around your brain while you're
doing this yeah you do and that's a big
part of it is identifying the um the
trauma in the body and how it affects
the body there's a book called um the
body keeps the score but I think his
name is Bessel he's a psychiatrist and
he's he's responsible for all these
Trauma Centers all over the country and
so this this guy is doing it to this
lady right now he's going back and forth
with his fingers and she's following his
fingers and so she's supposed to be
thinking about traumatic memories so
then he'll bring up he'll take her back
through the fir the first uh phase is
like identifying the trauma so it's a
lot of talk
therapy so you kind of you know talk a
lot talk a lot talk a lot and then the
therapist gets the idea of what you need
to go back and reprocess and new things
will come up when you go back and and um
and then you'll reprocess it it's not
just hands you can do uh you can follow
a ball you can hold the buzzers in each
hand it's about stimulating both sides
of your brain yeah what's happening in
mental health now is so fascinating
because when you parallel it with like
what happened in medicine right like we
used to treat the symptom right so if
someone had a fever they treated the
fever but they didn't know what the
cause was so they put you in cold water
or boiling water whatever they did and
then they found out about viruses and
bacteria so they started treating the
cause now in mental health you're you're
starting to see that Revolution because
of um you know the advances in
Neuroscience where they can look at the
brain and they can actually see you know
what parts are responsible for what
where trauma uh shows up in the brain
they just did another uh a recent study
it was a big study about how trauma is
doesn't traumatic memories don't come
back as memories they come back they
light up in the party brain as if it's
happening now which makes sense we knew
that because you know when Vietnam Vets
start bugging out and they're in the
supermarket or whatever but they can
actually see it now in the brain that
the brain is processing it as it's
happening now so um you know converging
neuroscience and psychology and all the
things that they've known from all these
different advances and it's it's it
seems to be in a place now where trauma
is becoming one of the things that they
focus on the most
like early childhood trauma or traumatic
events uh in war obviously we know that
that's you know a big that's the the
specific cause of what is bothering
those people you know is what they've
experienced and so now they're targeting
the trauma but they have ways to treat
the trauma with edmr with brain spotting
it's called um you know a whole bunch of
these um tactics that's really
fascinating it's really fascinating when
you think of like I had this guy on the
podcast yesterday uh Joe pyer he's a MMA
fighter for the UFC and he had a
terrible childhood terrible [__]
horrible beatings just constant be it's
just like heartbreaking to hear the
story but you gotta it's just
fascinating like as a human being like
whoever you are when you're listening to
this right now you are the accumulation
of your processing of every experience
you've ever had as much as we like to
claim autonomy we think on our own and
we kind of do and there's that like
again there's definitely chemical
problems there's definitely people that
just have a genetic defect something
just like some people have diseases of
all sorts of other parts of their body
they get diseases in the brain that's
[__] for real 100% but you're
basically just an end product of
experiences and your interpretation of
those experiences and the L leg the
lessons and the the way you've
contextualized all those experiences and
they're all in your head and that's your
map of the world that's your map of the
world so if you're in San Francisco yay
we freed Palestine like their map of the
world is [__] like their experiences
like what what's got them to 2024
January 18th or whatever it is is this
result sucks like this result sucks like
this is terrible like you guys are out
of your [__] mind you're wasting your
time there's needles on your street you
guys are out of your [__] mind what
did you what are you doing this this
result sucks but those people are they
could have been in [__] Wyoming like
hardworking ranchers the same human
could have been like a ass salt of the
earth [__] Kevin Coster Yellowstone
looking [__] it could have been
the same it's just your experiences yeah
it's just what do you what shapes you
what directions do you go in what when
do you get pushed down when do you get
lifted up who gives you a hug who pushes
you away and how does this how does this
play out yeah I don't think a lot of
people know themselves because you got
to do all this work to know yourself
because your brain protects you in so
many ways that you're unaware of like um
your brain will [__] they know in
Neuroscience like your brain usually
when it's healthy Works in concert and
sends information to different parts of
your brain to process it but when you
have trauma or chemical problem or
whatever it is it doesn't work well and
in traumatic uh experiences your Li your
your neocortex shuts off and your limic
turns on and that's a there's a surv
reason for that right so if you're in a
moment of fight or flight you don't want
to start reasoning you don't want to go
like you start philosophizing you just
emotional you're dealing with your
survival reptile brain and so it
actually shuts off so people who have
like panic and anxiety it's hard to
reason your way out of it because that
part of your brain is shut
down